merci michel en tout cas michel toutes
ces révélations interviennent quelques
heures avant le dépôt à l'assemblée
nationale d'une motion de censure de
l'opposition l'opposition qui avait déjà
fait de la ferme onea de ses principaux
cheval de bataille et qui a du mal
aujourd'hui à croire à une simple
coïncidence côté majorité et
gouvernement bien évidemment on se
félicite du succès de la police jean
baptiste prêts dédiés et jacques gérard
nous résume les réactions recueillies ce
matin à paris
la nouvelle a presque pris au dépourvu
l'assemblée dans les couloirs tout le
monde salue les résultats de l' enquête
sur le meurtre du préfet erignac
pour la majorité cette satisfaction
ressemble à du soulagement
la politique de rétablissement de l'état
de droit en corse conduite depuis deux
ans portait un plus bras et est
hypothéquée par le non aboutissement
de l' enquête sur l'assassinât du préfet
aujourd'hui cette hypothèque élevé c'est
un progrès considérable la droite
préparé pour cet après midi sa motion de
censure sur la corse officiellement les
plus concernées se réjouissent aussi y
avait une chape de plomb qui pesait sur
le dossier corse du fait de cette
affaire non élucidée
parmi une multitude d'autres donc
aujourd'hui
il ya une réponse à une attente profonde
et je pense que personne ne peut
contester
l'idée que justice soit faite mais
derrière la probation ont souligné les
coïncidences l' enquête aboutit alors
que le gouvernement était en difficulté
sur la corde et l'opposition reste
critique le si monsieur chevènement
ouvre les bouteilles de champagne pour
saluer une victoire de la police alors
dans ce moment à ce moment là lorsque un
préfet ait pris si je le dise dans une
sale affaire comme la sphère des
paillotes à ce moment là monsieur
chevénement aurait dû démissionner ce
qu'a fait la police judiciaire
aujourd'hui on peut s'en féliciter parce
que non seulement on aboutit mais ça
montre qu'il faut toujours respecter les
lois de la république
l'opposition comptait sur le débat de
motion de censure pour mettre en cause
la politique du gouvernement en corse
l'un de ses arguments les lenteurs dans
l' enquête sur l'assassinât du préfet
erignac l'argument est tombé et le
climat a changé